if you look maybe 50 years from now or
100 years from now a person born then
what do you think is a good goal in
terms of how long a person would live
like what is the maximum longevity that
we can achieve
through the methods that we have today
of uh
or are developing some of the things
we've been talking about
and in terms of genetics in terms of
biology
what's is there a number
right uh well so it changes all the time
because technology's changing so quickly
i keep
revising the number upward uh but i
would say that
if you do the right things during your
life and start at an early age let's say
25 we don't want malnutrition starvation
that's not what i'm talking about
but in your 20s start eating the kind of
diets that i talked about
skipping meals in animals that gives you
an extra 20
to 30 percent we don't know if that's
true for humans and that would
you know even five percent more would be
a good a big deal for the planet
i think that we should all aim to at
least reach a century
um i i'm i'm a little bit behind i was
born too early to benefit
the most from all of this discovery
those of you who are in your 20s
you should definitely aim to reach 100.
i don't see why not
consider this is really important the
average lifespan of a human
that looks after themselves and but
doesn't pay attention
is about 80. okay japan that's the
average age for a male
bit higher if you do the right things
in your life which is eat
healthy food don't overeat don't become
obese do a bit of exercise get good
sleep and don't stress
that gives you on average 14 extra years
that gets you to 94.
so getting to 100 if you just focus on
what i'm talking about it's not a big
deal
so what's the maximum well we know that
one human made it to 122 and a number of
them make it into their
teens i think that's also the next level
of
of uh of where we can get to with the
types of technologies that i'm talking
about
medicines like i mentioned rapamycin
there's one called metformin which is
the diabetes drug
which i take that in combination with
these lifestyle changes should get us
beyond 100
how long can we ultimately live well
there's no maximum limit to human
lifespan why can a whale live 300 years
but we cannot
we're basically the same structure we
just need to learn from them
so anyone who says oh you max max out at
x
i think is is full of it there's nothing
that i've seen that says biological
organisms have to die there are trees
that live for thousands of years
and their biochemistry is pretty close
to ours
you